[Music]
I've been writing prompts ever since
text to video has been around back when
it looked like this.
So now videos look and sound more like
this.
>> M that is absolutely divine.
>> The freshness of the basil really comes
through.
>> I've been using a technique I assumed
everyone used, but based on a poll I
did, what I'm about to show you is
apparently a well-kept secret. So let's
make it the worstkept secret. And the
secret is this. I don't actually write
my prompts. I train a GPT on the
official documentation for the model I'm
using. Then I give it my idea and let it
format the perfect model optimized
prompt for me. Now before you say this
is cheating,
>> this is cheating.
>> The art is not your prompt. The art is
your idea. Art is a perspective or an
intention. Prompting is like a
translator that turns your idea into
words that the video model understands.
So, we're going to look at why we should
do this. But first, let's look at how do
we do this.
The first thing we need is documentation
for the model we're using. So, here's
where you find it in Hyo. Here's Cling.
Here's Luma Dream Machine.
Here's VU.
Here's where you find it in Runway. You
actually have to find it in multiple
places in Runway.
For VO, you've got to go to the DeepMind
site and then click build with Gemini.
Go to the documentation and then VO
video generation and then prompt writing
basics.
And I usually just pretend like I'm
going to print it and then I save it as
a PDF. Uh, but you just need to save it.
Once you have the documentation for the
model, you can either upload it to a
chat if you're on a free plan or create
a custom GPT or GEM if you're on a paid
plan for chat GPT or Gemini.
In chat GPT, you go to GPTs and then
create, then upload the file in the
knowledge. Here's the knowledge and one
that I've been using for a while, but I
also have ones that are specific just to
certain models. All right, in Gemini,
make sure that this menu is out. Go to
explore gems, then click new gem, and
then add the knowledge.
In the instructions section, I usually
just put that this provides optimized
prompts for the user's ideas based on
the documentation. If you're on the free
version of either of these tools, um,
and this includes DeepSeek, you can
upload the documentation to the chat
window. Just remember that the longer
you chat, the more it's going to start
forgetting about the uploaded document.
So, I'd recommend a new chat for every
project. Looking at these two clips, I
actually like my original one more
because the other one is a little too
dramatic and over the top. So, rather
than trying to rewrite that prompt
myself, I can just say it feels too
over-the-top drama. I want something
more cinematic and emotionally subdued.
Now, just reading this sounds much
closer to what I had in mind than
reading this. And I like that it gives
you some additional suggestions, too.
Let's try to change what the camera is
doing just by describing the shot as we
picture in our mind. So, I want a
closeup of her face and then I want to
reveal what she's looking at.
And if I don't like that camera
direction, I can say, what if we start
on her face and pull back and orbit
around her to see her view?
Let's go back to the fog shrouded pier
prompt, but let's give her a Victorian
era attire.
For this one, I like it, but it's not
exactly what I'm looking for. I want her
to look at the ship at the end. I want
it to be a little bit more cinematic.
So, I can just go back to the prompt and
add that in there.
[Music]
So, now we're going to ask for a lone
sailor on the ship looking back at Short
where the woman is barely visible.
[Music]
I'll show you what I like about the
prompt sidekick that I was showing you
earlier. So, some of my placeholders are
like outline the best practices. So I
can just click that and it will look at
all of the knowledge I've uploaded and
it gives you a good list of best
practices. So if I have an idea for a
movie, I can give it this idea and then
say I want model optimized prompts for
whatever models I want to use. In this
case, runway, hyo, vu, vo, and cling.
And see which model gets closest to what
I had in mind. All right, so let's see
how this goes.
[Music]
That was the dumbest movie I ever saw.
>> I liked it.
>> You liked it.
>> What I like about this is I'm just
coming up with my ideas and I get to
focus on the story I want to tell or the
video I want to make. The big reason I
like this can be summarized in that meme
about I don't want AI to make movies. I
want AI to wash the dishes so I can make
movies. Like I said earlier, prompting
is a translator between your human idea
and the structured language of an LLM.
If I write a prompt manually, I'm
putting a lot of creative energy into
translating for my translator. I just
want to be an idea machine. And this
way, when I chat about my ideas, I'm
focused on my creative vision. Not just
what the picture should look like, but
how the person watching it should feel.
That conversation forces me to clarify
my thinking. It's what making art or
telling stories is all about. And
something I've been saying since one of
my very first videos on this channel,
generate and iterate.
When you get a bad result, tell your GPT
what went wrong or even attach a
screenshot and give it your perspective
on what went wrong and what you want to
see done to make it closer to what your
vision is.
Remember
like two years ago when people were
saying the highest paid new job is
prompt engineer. I think that convinced
a lot of people to think that manually
writing prompts was a valuable skill.
But the real focus should be on how to
express your idea. How can you
communicate what's in your imagination?
Being able to articulate what you want
to express is the skill you need for the
future. So focus on your own creative
expression and let AI translate for
another AI. Another way to say that is
if a computer is going to read it, I
trust a computer to write it. But if a
human is going to read it, I need a
human to write it. You've got a story to
tell. Leave the prompting to the
machines. My name is Mike. Thanks for
watching this episode of AI Video
School.
>> This is cheating.
cheating.